So many creative people talk about the
importance
failure in,
right?
The fact that it's okay to make mistakes
during the creative process.
Then to do anything creative,
you've got to take a risk.
Some kind of cognitive disinhibition is
necessary.
You need to cross the streams.
You need to cross the wires just a
little bit,
right?
A little bit of madness is necessary to
connect the dots in a new way.
Right?
Isaiah Berlin famously said to
understand is to perceive patterns.
That's in essence what creativity is.
Steve Jobs says creativity is just
connecting things,
but in order to see patterns and rather
in order to recombine existing patterns
into new forms and new shapes,
you need to be willing to blur the
boundaries between your thoughts,
right?
To be an associational thinker,
right to free style,
to ride a butterfly effecting thought,
but again,
most of the time we play it safe,
right?
We map out what we're going to say.
We preplan what we're going to do.
We make a list.
We have a set of steps.
We are prepared,
we've pre scripted ours beach or we are
responsible.
We're not going into a situation blind,
but again,
once in a while,
my friends,
we need to be willing to make a mistake.
We need to be willing to fail.
It is only when we risk making a mistake
that we might find ourselves
improvising,
inventing,
innovating our way back to where we want
to get to.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
Think of this rant as a metaphor for the
creative process,
right?
I have some what,
an idea of what I want to say,
right?
It's related to creativity and it's
related to cognitive disinhibition and
being willing to make a mistake.
That's all I know.
Then I start jamming about this and what
happens is I might lose myself in some
chain of thought,
right?
I just kind of lose myself in the
moment.
The metaphor might like confound me and
before I know it,
I don't even remember what I was saying,
but somehow that's when the creativity
kicks in because somehow I've got to
bring it back.
I've got a rope it in,
I've got to remember where I'm going.
I've got a summon coherence,
right?
Then the Bardos between one statement
and the other.
And in doing so and in risking screwing
up the video and the tape,
it is in that risk that the courage,
that the innovation,
that the creativity that the original
thought might emerge and usually does.
And before I know it,
I've landed and I feel like,
wow,
man,
I just took a trip,
man.
You know,
I just sailed into the great unknown and
I brought it back.
And here we are.
That is what creativity is all about.
That is the risk.
That is the willingness to fail and make
a mistake that is crucial to the
creative process.
So the wall,
my fellow thinkers,
writers,
painters,
poets,
original doors out in the world trying
to come up with an original vision,
trying to impact humanity through their
art and their artistry.
Go forth,
but be willing to fail,
be willing to make a mistake,
pick up the pieces and try,
uh,
yeah,
it is a ride and we're in it together.
My friends,
and if we have each other and respect
each other and tolerate each other's
failures and failings,
we will get to a much better,
much higher,
much more holy place.
And isn't that awesome?